what's going on man nitric it's good to
see you good how are you get both you
all at once
that's right why was I not here last
time we're Sam not here well I've
interviewed soldier yeah many times
yeah I see you a lot with lots of
various other people and big mm a guy so
I like to watch your oh thanks for you
know
yeah me and Matthew the yeah we've met
yeah you should we yeah I think if you
like the this poor you should come on
the podcast sometimes it's hard to get
celebrities who really love watching I'm
huge I'm a huge FC fan do you go to them
I do yeah what do you think about a
mutagen in Ghana we'll see we'll see
best I mean certainly best at 2018 so
far certainly I mean I know that's dumb
to say it's early but I it could be a
he's awesome
thank God is awesome I know yeah but I
like see paid to is just a big country
boy from Ohio yes doesn't lose anymore
I mean it's really just you know it's
from that perspective it's awesome do
you see that one going the distance no
no I don't but I mean if he does that
over him hit was unbelievably watching
man yeah we were talking about it cuz I
watched the last one weren't they saying
oh my god he hits like he has the
hardest hit in the world right now I
mean like they measure that I mean they
take me over him is taken some shots I
will say that but but he but that upper
that uppercut was insane I can't pick
fights either because we interviewed
over him right before that fight and I'm
like well you know and goners never
dealt with the guy who kicks like
Overeem or who has the knees that over
inna doesn't matter that just looping
uppercut and he was finished I think it
takes it takes a fight like that
sometimes to realize like that guy just
wins like all the time well they don't
work that's what's happened with ste
pays do just doesn't lose anymore he's
just got you know you look back you're
like who were his two losses you know
what I mean because he's been on such a
tear it was a junior and and who a
junior fight given I don't I was trying
to go the other day I don't exactly my
memory is getting really bad there's so
many fighters there's so many ways so
many
now do you train if you're trained or no
no I mean just for just for movie stuff
not I mean I'm a you know sounds lame I
mean I'm a CrossFit guy I don't I don't
do like jiu-jitsu or anything yeah
people are religious by their CrossFit
they're like cross yep
people love their cross they do it's
sort of yeah it's become kind of jerks
you know with your box name your box
your gym but it was literally Australian
sofas like what's your box name right
right right no I actually I'll watch
that online - I'm kind of CrossFit in
the game Wow I think that was just like
a workout thing that people were
obsessed with not that oh no just like
watch other people doing crossfit no no
we just crushed fit and something you do
with the group
it is yeah oh my you don't mind doing
that with a group you know it's funny I
always hated anything that resembled
some kind of class because I just can't
stand working out other people but then
I I kind of dig it cuz it does also a.44
like when you can go and you kind of you
know you got to have the right amount of
ego not to push yourself so much that
you hurt yourself but like you know if I
see like a 30 year old nerves like
really ripped I'm like right I'm gonna
try to keep up with him on these
segments so it does it does push you for
the guy who like misses sports it's kind
of good for like mid for these guys I'm
like that's right you know but like you
just miss that do you tap out sometimes
or can you always do it are you ever
like I can't no I mean there are some
things that yeah that I can't that I
can't do but you know we've got a great
gym so those so the coaches are very
they're able to say look if you can't do
this many whatever double-unders or
stuff then just do this what's a double
under it's when you swing the rope twice
on you know when you're jumping rope and
so I'm just going once you just go yeah
Oh spin it twice before your feet around
I am the worst I'm a really bad jump
Roper I don't like I can't do more than
like three in a row
it's like a yo-yo like you don't do it
unless like you're into it right right
yes women in there I've - I took a yoga
class one time a hot yo like a Bikram
yoga like three or four and it was hard
to breathe you know the women in that go
to that it's literally - 90% women and
there's just a couple of guys and it's
hard not to to really become a complete
creep and just stare for the entire
session yeah well
yes I mean the the CrossFit bodies by
nature they're the people who do it a
ton are just ripped you know so there is
there there's a lot so it's an hour is
an hour okay
I'm asking really awful question I don't
care waffle questions critics though
they say like in athletic cuz there are
athletes that do CrossFit now is like
they don't go to the gym anymore they do
CrossFit but they say that it it's over
long periods of time really bad for your
body because you push it too far and you
know that's the thing I mean it yes
that's exactly right cuz it does you you
it takes a lot of restraint mental
restraint because you're also doing I
can see the negative side of because
you're doing a lot of Olympic lifting
like when in life are you gonna do like
a power snatch on your own so if you're
getting into these things unless I you
know it sort of takes you back to like
high school like football things where
you're doing all those squats and sort
of heavy lifting but you know no one
does that
really unless you're relating to it do
they have levels like you're a beginner
level CrossFit take like like Alisa my
gym at gorilla fitness or Montclair you
gotta take I forget how many hours it is
but before they sort of let you loose in
a class cuz it again it's a you may
think I think I can do that that guy
looks smaller than me and he's squatting
that all the sudden you put it on
they're like oh god my back yeah so you
can get screwed up it just really is
because I heard the hesitation in your
voice like you're self-aware enough to
know you're like I you have to be like
my wife if she was this thing that she
would be just too turned off cuz she
can't stand hearing me talk about either
CrossFit or like marathons because you
do marathons too well yeah yeah yeah so
you've become such a jerk like we shut
up like I'm like well let me tell you
about my running style you know like it
takes it takes it is like hours and
hours to do it and so you want to tell
somebody about it yeah and then they're
like why would I care about that
I know but of course it's stupid of
course it's stupid it's so private like
no no one would enjoy it you're like you
run away from how many marathons have
you done for four or five that's pretty
amazing I mean it to run that far for
that long so you have to stop and pee
once in a while people have you ever had
while you're running I have not a lot of
people do they get it they do they get
famous stories of people doing it while
they're running I have not had that
problem the funny thing is though I'm
gonna help my brother-in-law my
brother-in-law you know ran a marathon
any-any and he had to take a dump in the
middle of it and so every time you say
hey what was your time he's like well he
didn't stop it actually did stop that
becomes his excuse you sitting there
when you marathon so like especially I
feel like it's time you keep working and
working working
you always pop up in new movies I feel
like have you ever been in a scenario
where you're running this marathon and
halfway through somebody's like you well
it's you know it usually takes people
people have to figure out who I am
anyway well forget it you just catch
people like running outside like 15
minutes just like running next to you
trying to figure out is that there is
that the guy yeah or I beat you I
totally be triathlon I would like to the
the problem is the the the training that
goes into that stuff and and for me
truthfully talking about that I I
haven't run him in a couple years
because when I when I went away and did
um
Aquaman I had to gain a lot of weight
and running is so counterproductive to
that so I so I had to because I can tell
when I look at myself in films that I've
run marathons in or around that time I
just I look really skinny so it's not
really a great look for me so but muscle
on to play Farhat yeah for to play yeah
I play or min the movie play his bad
half-brother okay when you have a bad
guy with a lot of people are talking
about Aquaman and like I think
regardless of what the reviews were for
Justice League I feel like everybody was
like you have a Jason Momoa was badass
like everybody was excited about Aquaman
you do you pay attention like now that
like you're a part of those universes do
you pay attention to be like oh well if
people don't like Justice League then
sure Aquaman might be like yeah sure
sure I mean you know and also Justice
League Zack Snyder who I did watch on
with is is a as a friend and I think in
unbelievable director so you you always
pull for your friends anyway and you
know you're part of the DC universe
right I was a voice of the president in
Batman vs Superman so even in that
little you know tidbit of lines you you
want to pull for those movies I mean I
think what what what DC does do or at
least in my experience done differently
than the Marvel least the first few
Marvel movies for me i watch you look at
Wonder Woman and how it just went on
it's it's its own and I think they've
and that R is a real credit to Warner
Brothers and DC for just letting the
director take it and run with it and it
clearly worked right like what amazing
unbelievable and and they've given James
1 our director for Aquaman who I did
insidious and conjuring with where yeah
they think just reminding our
CrossFitters who may not know my yeah
but but they've given James the the the
leeway to do his flicks so yeah you know
you're conscious of Justice League but
world thing has James why never done
anything like this before or was it he
had so much success in that genre that
they would like go where he did Furious
7 right when Paul Walker passed away in
the middle of shooting so I only bring
that up because one he's stepping into a
huge franchise and his one of his stars
passes away in the middle of it and then
he's still got to figure out an artful
and creative way too emotional way to
keep this franchise going and you know
and he did it do they have half that
movie shot in the head they just kinda
it was like when it was less died when
who is director Terry Gilliam was
directing that movie oh yeah yeah yeah
Johnny Depp and a couple of his friends
finished it yeah it was called yeah
doctor something or a mystery or
published a Parnham it was some cry I
know you're thinking doctor but yeah
really
I donated The Imaginarium of Doctor
Parnassus finish that with him was it
was like what like two or three guys big
fans I want to say it was Jude Law and
Johnny Depp I think that's right yeah
yeah that's right no I for I know for
for Furious 7 I mean it was
combo of amazing VFX and face
replacement and Paul's brother or at
least one of his brothers was a double
and you could in from far away you could
you could pull it off the way they did
that too because I believe watching the
movie like especially because it's such
a big story like you are watching for it
on believe I didn't catch it at all as
I'm watching it we don't know what part
that cuz they don't film in order so it
might have been the enemy exactly
exactly I know and then and then they
obviously have to write into the story
because they're gonna keep doing furious
trophies so they had to write into the
story that he dies and it actually like
all worked and I guess that's admitted
to James Bond right yeah yeah Philip
Seymour Hoffman had to do that to to he
died he's shooting something in a couple
of extra really well yeah and I'm
wondering Lee once computers are good
enough they're gonna have actors
probably go in and do a certain amount
of things where if they have to finish a
movie without you yeah I will tell you
that's a freaky thing and you're not
wrong I I will tell you even on and I'm
sure they do this with all these movies
now but but this isn't some great
spoiler but on on Aquaman and on all
these superhero movies when you're doing
a ton of stunts and there's a ton of VFX
you go into a little booth and you make
a whole bunch of funny faces and they've
have 100 cameras around you getting
every facial expression in case they
need to do that in case what you in
didn't need to put your face on a stunt
guy in case they need to do this okay
it's it's it's crazy how that has
changed the game well fast-forward 30
years what happens when they can capture
everything and all this time they don't
need you to make movies in him I will
not be I will not be here coach and a
marathon instructor it's also amazing
that like that's not even reserved
anymore for the like high-intensity
action movies like I think they did that
for I Tania so that they could get
Margot Robbie's oh you had I wonder how
they did it I'm in the business
yeah and that was unbelievable yeah you
are looking for it yeah how good was she
them she was really good she's amazing
she was she playing an older she playing
older Tania no she plays yeah she goes
she's awesome she goes through from the
time she's like 15 so that movies great
it's really really sad
I got the screener like you get those
community screeners yeah that and I
gotta watch it I started the Billboard
one that you didn't like and I'm gonna
be like three billboard you didn't know
I saw that I'm like 20 minutes I loved
it but I have to but I have to see
beyond yeah it's much different than I
though the trailers make it look a
little funnier than it is
well I dug it but I can see if people if
well maybe my people don't but the tone
is something I love the tone I'll
actually love I think Sam's unbelievable
I also love I mean it's like I love
everybody that's in it yeah like I just
didn't like the movie it wasn't for me
but yeah um did you I was just gonna say
it like it's just such balls for James
Wan to go he makes his name for himself
with you obviously and he not only did
you make his name but I feel like he
made blum house what it is right I mean
to some extent yeah I mean that he had
paranormal activity which was huge but
certain but certainly yeah I see what
you're saying for that genre from for he
is my understanding Jason bought a
paranormal so he wasn't charged from the
ground up but certainly farm insidious
and yes the the low-budget horror movie
with you know either because now that's
the name that's it yeah then you see him
do like get out then you see him do the
that amazing documentary on on HBO oh my
god with you know the murderer guy what
the turning around
nothing not making a murderer no no no
no it was though so terrible you know
about the the forget it famous murderer
yeah it was that man free no it was like
it won a bunch of awards it was you know
that where he revealed himself in the
bathroom Roberts thank you so blump so
Jason did that as well I'm just trying
to give him so you see how it's expanded
he is yeah but you're right
but but but then for James wonder than
like leave the genre entirely and jump
on to the various thing it which is a
huge risk and then to succeed there and
be like okay now I'm jumping into DC
yeah yeah his furious comes back in dust
conjuring to write because he felt like
he really wanted to get to put his stamp
on that
and then was you know prepping for this
it's also amazing that that like period
of your career has now spawned off where
you're over here working with James Wan
on Aquaman yeah and then over here
working with Veera on a computer and
she's she's good I mean she's awesome
yeah yeah I wish we had more doing this
movie but but she's she's pretty
fantastic
I use film you down the last two movies
that scared the [ __ ] out of me which was
the the conjuring and insidious
horrified me when I said I was a really
[ __ ] scary it was yeah yeah no one's
easy to scary camps though you're either
so for you you think and say this is
scarier than contra I'm not scarier but
it was scary both of them really scared
me and most of our movies you just enjoy
but they're not frightening we kind of
everyone knows every you know oh it's
it's gonna be scary no it's not okay
that but that movie really frightened me
yeah when you see insidious for coming
out just came out yeah there is a
weekend is there any part of you that
goes like oh that was mine like do you
claim do you have ownership feeling do
you want to do more than know I know I
mean I don't for me it's always there
more stories to tell I with that
franchise I don't I don't know how you
you you you bring back the Lambert
family I don't you know it's nice to see
Lin Shaye it's nice to see her leading
the franchise in a in a woman that's
been around the business for a long time
a female driven you know woman probably
in her 60s I don't even know but but
that's awesome to me that's inspiring so
I I love it I love sort of watching the
franchise succeed and grow and grow and
grow
absolutely so I mentioned by the way the
commuter comes out on Friday when I was
little with with Liam and it's it's so
it's a lot of fun it is a ton of fun
it's it's a real you know Hitchcock
drama shoved through an action movie
meat grinder so you get the best of Liam
and well yeah you get this like cool we
were talking minute earlier that it was
like even in the trailer like there's
this like it seems like this kind of
Twilight Zone II premise where you can
really sink your teeth into like like
almost like a whodunit type thing but
then it's also a Liam Neeson and that's
it what's funny is promoting it you get
all these words like it's a throwback
movie which almost makes you kind of sad
because they don't make it I mean he
carries a torch for these movies but
they don't make a lot of these movies
anymore right you know Studios don't
have the faith or the the story or that
I guess a star power to
keep keep it moving forward and so you
know that's why it was you you assemble
this cassia Jonathan banks Elizabeth
McGovern Sam Neil and you know Chris
Liam and Vera I mean that down the list
he wasn't like you're like looking at
cast like wow this is we I'd love do
theater with all these people this is a
great great cast of people but because
you don't get opportunities like this
that just you're just they're just fun
to do good time trains are pretty you
would take a train where you can sleep
in a sleeper car I want to think a train
across I could when I was a kid it was
terrible oh you didn't like it yeah I've
never done it I've never done it my
mother-in-law had to do it from New York
to Florida but that was cuz her her
husband at the time did not have any
papers never afraid so they took a train
and it was fine New York to Florida I
did it to Boston once and I got the one
with the sleeper car and I get to sleep
for a couple hours it was kind of New
York to Boston was probably from DC to
Boston but they have a sleeper card
stuff no no but I was uh I jumped on in
New York and I got the car I was going
to be an open Anthony many years ago I
got the car with the sleeper just to do
it did you sleep a little bit yeah it
was like a swingers car yeah woman being
pounded up boxer shorts to her and you
see the husband with his dumb boxers
walk in the mirror we all see the arm
come over augment comes on next
Christmas oh you know quite a ways we
are yes I'm sure we'll have to do some
sort of just no footage or reshoots or
whatever it is just because they need to
put it together are you worried about
reshoots now because now the story today
is that everybody's upset because Mark
Wahlberg got like a million dollar saw
and Michelle Williams got a thousand
dollars to reshoot go solve it that's
crazy
I thought it was 1.5 million to 1
million no no the headline makes it look
like I know I know nothing for sauces I
know nothing but I'm read the headline
like you yeah it says he got 1.5 and she
got like a thousand dollars oh my god
yeah I did I misread that I thought it
was 1.5 million to 1 million I read that
yeah I think that's like a 1% of what he
got I'm not sure just a major disparity
slightly yeah I don't know what's what
is in Hollywood though I mean that with
a equals in the film oh I have no idea
haven't seen the movie it's you know
it's very strange when you start getting
into like people's quotes based on their
not based on anything other than like
the you know the the days that they want
to shoot or their value I don't I don't
understand it and I've been that's not
I'm not I'm not that level so do you
when you're negotiating for a film or
whatever do you just leave it all to
your age and be like I don't want to
talk numbers or no no I don't know where
you want to be and no III like to know
just because I try to keep an eye on on
the career and what you're doing good
you know III you talk about insidious I
remember doing that movie knowing I
would I would go in the hole doing the
movie and not even like as a joke I got
like no no I because I read I was also
in my life I wanted to get my family are
thinking about getting a house so I
thought you know what let's let's rent a
house in LA and for what I paid to rent
the house in the neighborhood that we
wanted to rent it in which I guess is my
own fault what we wanted beating her
family so we rented this house it costs
me money to do the to do the movie but I
didn't care because I had I knew the
movie was gonna be successful so then
you're like okay I've done this one I
don't care what I get paid up front I
think there's potential for a sequel I
love this director yeah it all worked
out I knew it was gonna happen so I I
just I had a great feeling people in
your life going like you're crazy or do
they kind of go like okay yeah no
question they usually kind of they it's
it's a little about that well there's
never you're crazy but I do have a great
team in great in great lawyers the you
know great lawyer in Gretchen rush that
that will say listen you know cuz she
just sort of sees everything that that I
don't see like this is what's behind the
scene but I was trust your judgment do
you know so it starts with do you love
the script you love this director okay
then I don't mind
then I won't push for this and it's also
do you want to say no you're like no
I want to let this go and of course
they're like oh how [ __ ] aggressive
yeah it's like any business yeah and and
I'm sure there's some movies or it's
like I don't need to do this I don't
want to do this if the dates work out in
the timings right grind the cash is
there and I get along with the directors
share okay but if it's an Oliver Stone
movie or whatever you I'll give on that
I do that I have I'm and I say this
knowing how stupid it may sound but I've
probably turned down much more money
than I then I've certainly ever made
because I don't I don't I don't lead
like that I look at the script and what
it does for me if it's something I want
to do and really if it works out my
family you know I knew when James was
talking about Aquaman the first thing I
thought was being away from my family
because I knew he wanted to shoot it in
Australia and I you know I I have two
kids and and I've never been away from
more than like so I think it was like
seventeen days up until I shot Aquaman
then all of a sudden it's going
Australia for six months so I knew I was
gonna eat it and it was gonna suck and
it and it's it and it did being being
away did you fly it in there at all we
have to wrap up by the way yeah yeah
okay yeah I mean I was I would do like
eight weeks on in a couple weeks off so
I'd be able to come home and and then
they which still was terrible but it's
Aquaman it's for the kids yeah yeah you
know and they came down sure the kids
want to go to college you do acclimate